we're just days away from
music's biggest night our road to the
grammys series is highlighting some of
the nominees and this morning we are
talking to the one the only her the
four-time grammy winner is nominated for
get this eight grammys this year
including
album and song of the year her soulful
voice and stellar performances on some
of the world's biggest stages from the
super bowl to the oscars have captivated
audiences and worldwide guys she has
nearly
eight billion and counting combined
audio videos streams eight billion wow
exactly her joins us now only on cbs
mornings good to see you welcome
hi great to see you thank you good
morning
good morning um so let's talk about
these nominations when you first found
out that you were nominated for eight
grammys what went through your mind
oh my gosh i was so excited um i
couldn't believe it i was like whoa this
is crazy like i've done so much in the
past few years and this is just like i
don't know it was unbelievable um but
you know i think the thing that was the
most special about it was the other
names that were along with me and the
other women that were also nominated um
like doja cat who was i think had the
same amount of nominations as me or more
so it's really really dope to see you
know just the women killing it yeah and
the other thing that you've talked about
is reconnecting with fans i mean we've
all been living through this pandemic uh
we haven't been able to see live
concerts for almost two years you're
finally going back out on the road how
does that feel
oh my gosh i'm so excited there's
nothing like that connection of course
you can do stuff you know video and and
uh online it's streaming but it's really
not the same as feeling the people and
and being able to see the faces and
people to hear the loud music
i talk about feeling the people i want
to hear about the role of squeak
because this coming back with the
musical version of the film the color
purple what's it like to have known that
you're going to play this part iconic
formerly played by raydon raydon chong
oh my gosh i'm so excited people are
going to see me in such a different way
of course the the legacy of of the color
purple is is so big and and it's crazy
that i get to start um with such an
amazing cast and amazing director and
this this legacy it's it's insane so i'm
i'm so excited i can't wait for people
to to see me on the big screen how are
you preparing for the role
man there's a lot of uh um you know
trying to practice my voice and and
really dive into squeak i'm like reading
the book and just studying the character
but i'm like trying to make sure that
i'm not speaking like a 1930s southern
woman you know on stage and at the
grammys while i'm preparing for this
role but um yeah it's it's a it's a lot
and it's it's fun it's a learning
experience for me
well your voice has been working for you
for a long time you first sang on
national tv when you were 10
at 14 you already had a record deal so
with that in mind i got a little
throwback for you a picture of you as a
kid playing in your father's band oh
my gosh with now 8 billion streams i am
curious when you see that photo what
comes to mind
man it almost brings me to tears just to
think about the journey and you know the
parts that people don't see the the hard
work and and the sacrifices that are put
in and the 10 plus years of working on
my craft and you know people just see
the tip of the iceberg so i'm proud of
myself and i'm happy that i can say that
i'm so proud of my journey and how far
i've come
you know her looking at that picture i
didn't know tony was going to show that
picture but i see your dad playing that
guitar and you made history a couple of
years ago when you became the first
black female artist to have a signature
guitar by fender right and i see you
playing it in your gigs i see you
playing it on stage all the time and you
you that was important for you because
your dad played offender i actually got
to play your guitar too i got to say
it's very cool but just seeing your dad
holding that stratocaster and you
playing that stratocaster with your
signature guitar has got to mean
something to you
oh my gosh i remember my mom kind of
borderline like being upset because he
like used the last bit of his paycheck
you know to buy me a guitar like he
would always
you know put my happiness above
everything and and supported me in music
so it it just makes me really really
proud and and so happy that that i had
him and that we had that
um can i just ask you i read in an
interview once that you said that alicia
keys told you that all you need in life
are three chords and the truth
how has that sort of defined your career
since you heard that from her
you know it's crazy because um ever
since she told me that i feel like it
was confirmation but also like just an
extra push to fully be authentic and to
fully speak my truth and my music and
it's not always an easy thing to do and
it's easy to say i'm going to write a
love song today or i'm going to just you
know come up with a cool concept but to
really think about what you feel and to
talk about it
and elaborate
and and make it poetic or make it
romantic you know um i really live by
that now and it's it's um it's really
important and i think it cuts through
way more when you when you speak your
truth and your music
well we feel that truth we feel that
love every time you step onto the stage
or you go into a recording studio
congratulations on the nominations
congratulations on the movie role we're
cheering for you
thank you so much
thank you for joining us you can watch
the 64th annual grammy awards this
sunday at 8 pm eastern 5 p.m pacific
right here on cbs